أجنبي
23 أخيرًا علينا ومعه يأتي
الترقب لأكبر
مسابقتين للفريق في لعبة الجولف حيث
يتجه كأس رايدر إلى إيطاليا ويتم استضافة الكأس الاحتفالية
هنا في حدث ضخم
[موسيقى] في إسبانيا
وهو حدث نما في
الماضي  منذ سنوات قليلة جدًا ،
إنها المرة الأولى في إسبانيا التي
نستضيف فيها كأس سولهايم ، لذا فهي بالنسبة لنا
لحظة فخر للغاية ،
فرانشيسكو دي لا لانكستر هو
المدير العام هنا في finka courteseen وهو
يشرح ما الذي يجعل هذا المكان مثل هذا المكان
وجهة خاصة للعب الجولف ،
أعتقد أنه من الواضح أن جودة
التصميم وجودة الهندسة الزراعية
وجودة الخدمة ، لذلك أعتقد أن
لدينا حزمة كاملة حقًا هنا في
فنجر كورتازين
مع كأس الصالون على بعد أقل من تسعة أشهر
والمضمار يبحث عن
الاستعدادات الأصلية  أوشكت على الانتهاء ،
لذا فقد
أتيحت لنا
الفرصة للترحيب بسوزان
عدة مرات في المنتجع ،
لذا فهي تأتي في كثير من الأحيان وهو أمر
رائع لأنه من الواضح أننا نحصل على الكثير من
ردود الفعل منها ثم استطاعت ستايسي لويس
أن تكون هنا أيضًا في
زيارة واحدة وكان ذلك رائعًا أيضًا لقد أحببت
المكان الذي ذكرت أن الخضر كانت
رائعة
مثل جميع دورات فنكر كأس سليمان الرائعة التي
تم إعدادها
مع لعب الجولف.  في الاعتبار ، استضفنا
مباراة فولفو العالمية في ثلاث
مناسبات ، كانت التعليقات هائلة
من جميع اللاعبين ،
لذا أعتقد أنه سيكون
تحديًا كبيرًا بصرف النظر عن أن حالة
ملعب الجولف وصيانته
دائمًا ما يكونان رائعين ، لذا أعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك  أن
يكون ملعب جولف مناسبًا لكأس سولهايم